this week several unemployment claimants
have been looking for answers regarding
future lost
wages benefits and overpayment
notifications that were sent out
joe moeller's been all over this story
he's following these problems throughout
the week he's now live joining us with
an update joe
well brian deter did notify us a short
time ago that the pool website is
operating a little slower than usual and
they are working to address that there's
no time frame on
when that pool website will get
operating back to normal but we did
speak to
get some answers from dieter today on a
number of topics including the
overpayment notifications that went out
earlier this week and also the lost
wages benefits that's the extra 300
bucks
we did learn that there is a week five
of those benefits
unemployment claimants in nevada have
been wondering if they will see a week
five of lost wages benefits i've heard
nothing about it coming out i'm
wondering if i'm still eligible for it
if there's any funds left for it because
i was thinking i could possibly
be eligible for weeks five and six if so
dieter tells us week five will happen
possibly starting next week
earlier this week a large amount of
overpayment notices were sent out to
claimants
we spoke to many who were hoping it was
a glitch they're sending out
disqualification letters to people who
are qualified they are sending out
overpayment letters to people who've
never been paid
i had filed since april 4th so they made
the payments to me
and i have no idea why they sent me an
overpayment
adider sent us reasons as to why they
went out
according to dieter claimants who were
eligible for regular ui benefits must
apply in ui
if they had claims filed in both systems
the payments they received under pua
would be
overpayments or they may have received
pool payments based on the earnings they
reported
if the documents they uploaded show a
different level of earnings
they may have an overpayment but if they
do tell us to appeal of course i'm going
to have to because
that's you know what you got to do as
for appealing those notices deters says
pua claimant should go to employ
nv.gov portal and click on the
unemployment services link
ui claimants should follow the
instructions that come with the notice
[Music]
as far as week six for lost wages
benefits there's no word yet on if that
will happen
reporting live joe muller 8 news now